[Music]
i'll be back
thank you so much um thanks for having
me
so i've been spending the last couple of
hours
meeting a bunch of people here and it
really allowed me to kind of frame up
where i wanted to go with
my talk and and i think the word that's
most populated
to my mind at this conference so far is
patience i think that when i think about
blockchain or crypto
when i think about ar and more
importantly when i think about my career
i think the word patience is something
that needs to be talked about here
this this afternoon has been a lot of
fun for me because
it's kicking me vibes of the social
media conferences i went to
in 2005 6-7
it's kicking me vibes to the feelings i
felt
when i launched the e-commerce wine
business in 1996
a lot of the conversations today have
been around
when does this go mainstream when is it
accepted you know
when how all these kind of themes that
i've seen two or three other times
there was a time where i went to search
conferences
where people were like when's search
gonna be accepted
and then all the way back to the
beginning when would the internet itself
be accepted for all the youngsters in
here who are spending a disproportionate
amount of time
to justify blockchain or crypto i want
to remind you that there was a time when
the internet
itself was a fad the first conference i
ever went to
that looked like this i sat in a chamber
of comfort
commerce event on a panel where
literally old people made fun of me
for 45 minutes because they laughed at
the idea that people would buy
wine on the internet and multiple people
on the panel that i was on
said that by the year 2000 the internet
would not exist
i really i really want to give a piece
of advice from a
old-timer and who's been through a
couple of cycles of innovation
if you spent as much energy
that you spend on debating whether
crypto or blockchain
are going to succeed if you took that
same energy
and actually became a practitioner in
the execution
within your craft you would be much
further along
100 to me
debating who's going to win a basketball
game in the first quarter
when the game's actually going to end
and there's going to be a score up there
is kind of silly in its nature so
if i could leave you with anything from
my perspective and there's a lot of
interesting people speaking
during this conference i i would highly
recommend
deploying a lot more patients you know
whether you're right or their right
it's completely irrelevant it's going to
play out and then we'll all monday
morning quarterback
a lot of times when people debate me and
i can see that this is just a religious
debate there is no conversation it's not
a debate
it's just an argument i often end with
cool i'll see you in 2028 right there is
no other conversation
and so that's just one tidbit there's
another tidbit
99 of the browsers and search engines
that people made lots of money on in
valuation
in the mid 90s went out of business i
think it's
very important for people in this space
to understand
that it is likely that 90 to 98
of the currencies will not make it
and so there's always moments in time
where there's
and what's so incredible about this
space is there's liquidation along the
way
unlike when i was investing in early
stage startups you invested
and it was either feast or famine there
was no liquidation along the way which
is what has attracted a lot of the
behavior
in this space but i please i need people
to understand
to me blockchain as a technology is a
foregone conclusion
but the currencies that are built on top
of that have enormous volatility
for all the people here that like to
tell each other how they made a million
bucks in 12 months from
zero i want everybody know this is just
my real life
i have over 10 000 direct messages and
emails in my inbox right now
of people who maxed all their credit
cards and bought bitcoin at fifteen
thousand
right who are in deep [ __ ] [ __ ] who
are in
massive depression and sadness so please
understand that we're
when we're in these spaces there's
enormous volatility
and it's very [ __ ] early like
real early like real [ __ ] early
and i think that the lack of patience of
proving you were right
or needing to make 10 million bucks or
whatever the [ __ ] is going through your
mind
is the vulnerability the lack of
patience in this collective
all of us here together all the fancy
people in the back and all the people
here
our collective vulnerability is lack of
patience
and so i genuinely believe
that if you're one of the two or three
people here who can fundamentally change
your path
from the quick score because of the gold
rush
nature of the oxygen in the room
to do you actually believe in blockchain
do you believe a decentralization and
start being meaningful
i believed in social media in 2006
there was a lot of people who came and
went in 2006 7 8 9
10 who had a lot of twitter followers
there's a substantial reason
that i was able to see it all the way
through and be in the space
with the longevity because my behavior
wasn't helter skelter
it wasn't my pants weren't on fire
because i thought this social media
thing
would be gone tomorrow i am completely
convinced
and this is not a disrespectful comment
i am completely convinced
that more than half this room thinks
that it's a quick score game
and have no sense or even are educated
enough to understand how this all plays
out
and i think within that is your
opportunity because i will say this
for the group that's here you have such
a substantial
advantage over 99 of people
because you understand this is actually
even happening
the 99 of the people in the world
understanding of blockchain or crypto is
the word bitcoin and that's where it
starts and ends
99 in the collective 7.7 billion people
please do not underestimate the ability
of you being somewhere early like you
are
however i just want people to
take score of what's actually happening
this weekend here
and what's the opportunity at hand i
think the other thing
that i'm very passionate about
is understanding the media landscape
that we live in
during this revolution several people i
know here
intimately there's others that i know
from afar i think the one great
opportunity for everybody here
is to understand what this is actually
all about
right just understanding the foundation
of us
living in a mobile environment
one thing that i think a lot of people
need to understand
is how to leverage the current mobile
social environment
in your crypto ar future technology
world
if you really look at the history of
people that have won
or have had success within new
innovations they were able to leverage
the current
main innovation in a way to progress
so many people here have been able to be
successful
in monetizing cryptocurrencies on the
back of building personal brand
and being given tokens in exchange for
pr services
or vlogging or things of that nature
please understand we are absolutely in
the eye of the storm
of the golden era of social media right
now we sit here
while instagram story ads are 2 cpms
and if and have swipe up call to actions
and it's so uncomfortably underpriced i
don't even know what to do with myself
i'm like pouring a hundred thousand
dollars a week into ad like
i don't know i don't even know how to
squeeze it any [ __ ] harder
so for a lot of people here so many of
your ambitions
are predicated on you communicating to
the world
please don't do what most people do
which is they jump to the next thing
before they squeezed
the current thing one of the great
mistakes in my career
happened in 2007 i was
literally one of the first people ever
to produce a youtube video that was
longer than five minutes long
literally i had the longest consistent
long-form show on youtube in 2006 and
seven
but because of my impatience or because
i chased economics
a platform came along called viddler
which was a youtube competitor
and offered me seven percent of the
company to move my show
wine library tv to viddler i did that
because it seemed ridiculous seven
percent
it seemed like a great deal but what i
left on the table was my deep
understanding that youtube was right
and all the attention and equity that i
could have built over that time
i believe that a lot of people here are
getting so
high on the supply of being right about
crypto or blockchain
that they're glossing over and thinking
things like social and mobile
are yesterday and we're gonna see
another seven to ten year
foundational run for those platforms so
please be thoughtful
in the way that you're mixing your
energies and your executions i believe
that the things that are current right
now are absolutely foundational
in your ability to extract value from
them
for what you're looking for to do a
couple other things
that i think are important you need to
understand the human spirit
in new technologies in 1996
i thought by the year 2000 every single
person
would come into my dad's liquor store
with a cell phone and scan the barcodes
and know the price of every wine in the
country and so i literally lowered the
price of every wine in my dad's store to
cost
or the best price on the internet
because what i didn't understand was how
long it would take to be accepted
online dating was in play for over a
decade before it was culturally accepted
i think a lot of people here are making
bets on singularity
on ar on vr on crypto on blockchain
you understand it you're beginning to
understand it and you're making
decisions based on your belief that
it will be accepted or at scale in 24
36 and 48 months no question
the thing that makes me different at 42
than i was at 24
is my understanding in how much slower
new technologies are
and how easy it is for us to get into
the bubble of this conference
and feel like everybody knows what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
but just for fun tonight when you go to
the casino
or the strip club or whatever the [ __ ]
you do
when you go talk to normal people about
crypto
pay attention that 99.9 of the people on
the strip today have no idea what the
[ __ ] you just said
knowing i don't have a lot of time i'm
going to say a couple other things that
are a little more macro and then
i'm sure we'll do a bunch of stuff in q
a the most macro thing i can tell you
is that self-awareness is fundamentally
the most important [ __ ] i've ever seen
in my life
i am so addicted to this thought process
if i could wish you anything besides
health it would be self-awareness
once you have self-awareness once you
actually understand
who you are so much crazy [ __ ] happens
and so i'm unbelievably aware that you
have ambitions i
think all of us have versions of what we
wish we were
versus understanding what we actually
are you know
i would be thrilled to be the starting
quarterback of the new york jets
that's not going to happen but very
early on in my life i was aware that i
was more likely to buy the new york jets
than to play for them
and what that allowed me to do is to
triple down on my entrepreneurial spirit
as a 10
11 13 year old you know if i could leave
any legacy from this talk today it would
be to get somebody to understand
that maybe they're not a number one and
they should do a startup
but they're a number three and should
support the [ __ ] out of a great number
one
i always tell my entrepreneurial friends
number 12 that facebook
made more than number one of 99.99999
of companies in the last 15 years
if you can actually understand what
you're about a lot of you shouldn't be
vlogging
a lot of you shouldn't be investing and
and
that is not a negative that's a positive
and so
i i unbelievably want to start
instilling things like self-awareness
and patience because i can tell you one
thing how many people here are under 30
raise your hands
i really wish you knew what it felt like
to be 42
and i'm sure a lot of people here how
many people over 40
what all of you know what i know is it's
[ __ ] crazy that
24 feels like 42 feels like 67.
it's always there it's always there
and if you actually knew how long you
know one of the most
fascinating things i'm paying attention
to is our inability
to understand how long our [ __ ] life
is
the amount of people that go into crisis
at 18
22 and 30 in our society is laughable
and so please understand
that for me the biggest thing that i
could have delivered this
evening in this talk is putting the time
frame of blockchain and crypto into
perspective i will also say one other
very macro thing
that i think is super important for me
as you navigate how you're gonna bet
your life in this world
if you actually understand blockchain if
you actually
understand the framework of what we're
talking about here
not what litcoin's going to be in
[ __ ] seven months
no the actual framework of what
blockchain means
the thing that i have not been able to
really get my head around
that i'd be fascinated feel free to dm
me and talk to me about it
is i hope we all can accept the
following statement as
truth if you actually understand
blockchain
it's really hard to wrap your head
around how russia china
and america are going to accept and
allow this to happen
i think it's very important for everyone
to actually understand this
if you actually understand what
blockchain does
it takes away all the leverage that the
countries
in our world have outside of their
atomic bombs
and their armies it is a substantially
big platform it is a revolutionary 2.0
of all the things that enter the
internet my friends
has fundamentally started to drastically
impact our culture
because it's taken the middle and it's
given it back to us
all the political not just the voting
the things we talk about
whether it's me too or black lives
matter or anything else
that's even secondary to those true
issues
i hope everybody understands that all
our shortcomings as human beings
have been protected by the media
infrastructures of the last
100 years and are losing their
leverage which is why we're having
different conversations and making
progress
blockchain takes that [ __ ] to a whole
[ __ ] another place
which is why it's actually far more
vulnerable than i think this room
understands
in parallel while we think about
decentralization
i hope you understand what's happening
across the world at a country level
because we're living through the growth
of nationalism
right if you think america is putting up
walls with tariffs and actual debating
walls
go look at what's happening at in india
right now go look at what's happening
across the world we are now more than
ever
over the last 70 years seeing countries
build
internal mental walls which are in
complete conflict
with something that looks like
blockchain this is a
very very big deal one that is
often not respected
by people that are enthusiasts of macro
new trends
let me give you the comp that will make
sense to you
when instagram copied the feature
of snapchat stories and pretty much
pulled off a pretty substantial punch in
the [ __ ] face to snapchat
it created everybody in the social media
world
to understand that you better not build
a feature because the ability of an
incumbent like facebook apple
or something of this ilk to copy that
and stop you from growing
is a very big deal if you look at what's
happening with the scooter movement
a lot of the cities and states are not
going to get tricked this time the way
they did with uber
the internet has really [ __ ] up the
status quo
the people that have leverage are not
just gonna sit
with their [ __ ] hands on their ass
and let blockchain
do a 2.0 version of that please
understand that if you believe in
nirvana
of complete and utter blockchain at
scale
that you're talking about substantial
world war three [ __ ] dynamics
and so while everybody's walking around
and thinking about
short-term economics and the quick
scores they're making on the currency
that's built on top of these frameworks
and the flip they made to change their
short-term lives
which is phenomenal and inspiring and
super [ __ ] cool i hope that there's
certain people in here
that are starting to deploy 5 10 and 20
year windows
because if you are and you're thoughtful
about it
the economics but more importantly the
legacy that you can leave
becomes remarkable and i promise you
for anybody in here who's made a dollar
or two in their lives
very quickly money stops mattering and
other [ __ ]
starts taking over so it's really
[ __ ] cool you made a million bucks on
some [ __ ] cryptocurrency
i don't give a [ __ ] what i care about is
you're actually here which means you are
fundamentally
point zero zero zero zero one percent
ahead of
society in your opportunity i hope
that you give the meaningful thought
process and strategy against this
advantage you have
because when i saw people have it with
social and when i saw people have it
with email
and with search and with the internet
itself 99.9
of them [ __ ] blew it because they
were going for the short-term score
because they didn't respect in the macro
opportunity
you have one life do something with it
thank you
thank you
thank you
you